this video is brought to you by
scentbird
what's up guys michael here now is it
just me or are we living in a
never-ending cuffing season instagram's
wallpapered with that classic shot and
it seems like every other reality show
is obsessed with helping people find
their one true soulmate
and yet even as monogamy is plastered
across our screens polyamory is still on
the rise it's estimated that 20 of
single adults have engaged in a
consensual non-monogamous relationship
at least once so is monogamy natural in
the first place what's more is it even
ethical and with the recent rise of
polyamory is monogamy headed towards
extinction let's find out in this
wisecrack edition why is monogamy weird
but before we get into it i want to tell
you about this video sponsored scentbird
scentbird is a fragrant subscription
service to let you try out scents from
cool brands you've never heard of and
from luxury brands you might not
otherwise be able to afford now instead
of investing in a huge bottle of scent
that you don't actually like or that you
won't be able to use before its shelf
life expires scentbird takes all the
risk out of choosing a personal
fragrance and they make it fun by
offering scents for more than 600 brands
for you to try such as prada confessions
of a rebel and gucci and because
scentbird works directly with these
brands you know you're spritzing
yourself with the real stuff every month
your subscription includes a new
fragrance of your choice packed in a
cute bottle that holds a 30-day supply
it's perfect for taking a new scent for
a test drive or for mixing up your scent
with the seasons this month i received a
versace perfume that's right your boy
can afford versace now um and it's the
versace poor home or for him and i
really like it it has sort of a a
springy smell there's there's lemon
there's sage um i've never really
thought of myself as a perfume guy or a
cologne man but i like this a lot and
just look at how efficiently
this works
can you hear it
just listen to that right it's asmr
that's what that means now if you aren't
sure where to start senberg can point
you in the right direction with help
from a handy online quiz this flexible
subscription lets you skip any month
without penalty so if you've got nothing
to lose stick to one cent per month for
just 16 or upgrade to try out two or
three cents every month instead all of
your scents will arrive in cute and
colorful cases that look great on your
dresser or countertop if you're in the
u.s or canada and you want to get 55 off
your first month of scentbird go to
scentbird.com and enter code wisecrack
at checkout that's promo code wisecrack
to get your first fragrance for just
seven dollars and now back to the show
first off let's talk terminology in the
past monogamy used to mean one marriage
till death do us part but we currently
understand it to mean engaging in one
relationship at a time polyamorous
individuals in contrast engage in
multiple relationships at a time or in
the case of polygamy are married to
multiple people at the same time now it
turns out that despite most of western
society practicing monogamy lots of
contemporary philosophers actually dig
polyamory and this is nothing new two of
the greatest philosophers of the 20th
century and total power couple simone de
bevoir and jean-paul sartre were making
the case for consensual polyamory almost
a century ago deb of war was a pioneer
of second wave feminism and sartre is
often credited as the father of 20th
century existentialism they were
basically the beyonce and jay-z of
french philosophy
simone and jean-paul met in paris in
1929 when they were both studying for an
extremely prestigious exam it was her
classic love story he placed first she
placed second thus academic success lit
the flames of what might be called a
50-year soul partnership that was sexy
and romantic but
not exclusive notably the two never once
lived under the same roof and though
their unconventional love life wasn't
awesome for their reputations these two
were down for it because it aligned with
their philosophical ideals importantly
de bevoir believed in authentic love
which she described as the reciprocal
recognition of two freedoms in layman's
terms neither partner is subordinate to
the other and neither derives all their
meaning from the other in layman's
layman's terms romeo and juliet ain't
[ __ ] so archer took it a step further
love wasn't a blissful merging of two
freedoms but a constant struggle in a
monogamous relationship you dominate or
are dominated either way freedom is lost
for him the best way to handle this
issue was to leave himself and his
partner open to loving as many people as
they wanted and interestingly their
respective positions parallel elements
of the philosophies they were espousing
at the time too so were these brainiacs
on to something or were they just two
fun french alcoholics to understand why
sartre and deborah's relationship still
feels weird or unusual we need to look
at how monogamy became the norm monogamy
as we know it has only been a thing
since the late 17th to early 18th
century at the time philosophers like
emmanuel kant and friedrich nietzsche
were totally on board kant saw marriage
as the only solution to the problem of
using people for purely selfish reasons
by being married you use your partner
they use you back and the cycle goes on
so a little less selfish and super
romantic am i right then again he also
thought the marital sex cycle was only
virtuous if procreation was a
possibility so if you really love bone
and down get ready for a cheaper by the
dozen scenario nietzsche was even less
lovey-dovey about relationships he was
pro-monogamy anti-romance his advice was
to marry your best friend which is a
very sweet start but he also advised
ignoring appearances and romantic
feelings completely he also had some
pretty unsavory views surrounding love
like that all your wife needs to be
happy is a baby so it's no surprise
several of his marriage proposals were
turned down and he died lonely and
miserable but if monogamy is still a
relatively new concept what were we
doing before you ask well in ancient
times the goal of marriage was
procreation so polygamy was a-okay we
should note that historically the
majority of polygamous situations came
in the one-man to multiple women model
while this sounds not ideal for the
ladies there were advantages when
survival was at stake you were much
better off as the wife of a resource
rich fat cat than as the miss weasley of
a penniless beggar and we know society
swung this way because of hammurabi's
code and the bible which agree that if
your wife couldn't reproduce there's no
shame or sin in taking one who can then
greece and rome changed everything with
the creation of socially imposed
monogamy which at the time was geared
more toward practicality than romance
you see monogamy is far better suited to
building large armies that's because
polygamous societies ran into female
scarcity problems with multiple women
married off to the same high ranking
group of men the common man was kind of
screwed
or or not screwed as it were
yet because because he doesn't get
anyone so he usually either skipped town
in search of a wife or
turned to crime when society shifted
toward monogamy there were finally
enough women to go around for all the
men regardless of their social status
with wives on luck men would more
productively contribute to society by
doing stuff like inventing the aqueducts
and going to war and thus monogamous
marriage became law although you could
have sex with other people so
don't worry about that but despite
greece's shift towards monogamous
marriage plato was pro-poly in his
perfect world families would be communal
people would take on lovers on mass and
sickly offspring would be thrown off a
cliff plato also came up with the
concept of platonic love which has been
misinterpreted over the years like a bad
game of telephone whereas people today
see platonic love as sexless friendship
plato originally described a ladder of
love where the bottom rung is carnal
attraction to someone's physical
appearance and the top rung is platonic
love in which one is more entranced by
someone's mind than their body and
contemplates more spiritual matters like
supreme beauty and the divine but as
christianity rose to dominance it did
not subscribe to plato's pro-poly
messaging with a side of chucking kids
off mountains instead in the middle ages
the christian church doubled down on
monogamy see christianity added
religious stakes to the whole thing if
you wanted to make god happy you would
share your body with only one other
person never mind that the bible has
plenty of polygamists like jacob and
solomon as is often the case there was
an economic motivation to push the idea
of monogamy it was the best way for the
church to get the aristocracy's riches
after all one spouse means fewer
opportunities to have children
especially sons who could inherit your
wealth don't have a son when you die oh
no guess all your money is going to your
younger brother instead who while you
are busy being a lord very likely has
joined the clergy it was a pretty plush
and popular gig for second sons your
money becomes his money which becomes
the church's money so on some level
monogamy shifted from being a mating
system centered around procreation to
being a marriage system that ensured the
church's coffers stayed full this
continued on until around the time of
the french revolution by this point
people were tired of marriages of reason
an enlightenment-era trend where people
were encouraged to get married purely
out of financial interest because it
turns out these led to very unfavorable
outcomes like adultery or domestic
violence so we kicked reason to the curb
transitioned from the age of
enlightenment to romanticism and
embraced marriages of feeling release
the doves
okay with the forgot the dubs like
angsty teens determined to be the
opposite of their parents romantics
hated unions predicated on finances and
practicalities sure some people were
still trying to land the richest dude in
town but the overall vibes had changed
because romantics were adorably hopeful
about marriage they believed that the
honeymoon phase should last forever and
dopamine-induced passion should never
fade you guys are so sweet together
cause we're still on our honeymoon 35
wonderful years of he feels like two to
me note scientists have now determined
that dopamine release as a result of
relationship excitement fades over time
and eventually stops
yikes but back then this natural
occurrence was a sign that your marriage
was on the rocks romantics also believed
that true love means accepting and
delighting in everything about your
partner including the fact that her
family visits her constantly and they're
all they're always there they're just
they're you're never you never get to be
alone they're always there the madness
didn't stop there in an incredibly
destructive move they made love
synonymous with sex mind-blowing
frequent sex became the benchmark of a
good relationship and infrequent sex and
or infidelity suddenly became huge
offenses true love became a cure-all for
loneliness why complete yourself when
your partner can jerry maguire it for
you you
complete me romanticism also taught us
that we should be able to intuit our
partner's thoughts and needs that's
right romanticism discouraged open
communication society so wholly embraced
these romantic ideals that even in the
secular world it was to your political
advantage to make sure everyone knew how
much you loved your wife is this
sounding eerily familiar and certifiably
chaotic it should because the template
for contemporary romance was laid by
these moony-eyed romantics and their
unrealistic understanding of love is a
major reason why we suffer from
heartbreak and spend a crap ton on
couples therapy today so why are we
still doing this chaotic tap dance from
over 200 years ago in part you can think
the industrial revolution which brought
an influx of people moving from farms to
cities as a result people became less
concerned with having enough kids to
mana plow and with fewer kids to wrangle
it became easier to focus on the quality
of your marriage and the weakening of
religious and community bonds made
monogamy more important than ever fewer
friends and family members meant you
needed your partner to take on more
roles best friend therapist sex god and
hey monogamy has its perks committing to
one partner over time can lead to
greater intimacy and it can feel nice to
have someone's undivided attention
interestingly enough polyamory and
swinging did have a brief resurgence
after world war ii created a scarcity of
men in a less dramatic version of why
the last man widows of the war were
taken in by married men who survived
group marriage and open relationships
ramped up in the 60s and 70s until aids
took all the momentum out of the free
love movement but nobody puts polyamory
in a corner eventually the internet gave
us broader access to potential partners
and apps helped poly people find each
other but were not finished talking
about the connection between wealth and
monogamous marriage socially imposed
monogamy even in loving marriages still
functions as a way to protect wealth and
couples who got married in the 20th
century were better able to pull
resources since women were more likely
to have access to their own money or an
inheritance today not only are rich and
well-educated people more likely to
marry they are also less likely to get
divorced and because people typically
marry within their socioeconomic class
the rich get richer while the poor
remain unhitched and broke fewer people
are walking down the aisle in the first
place because millennials are put in
financial security before marriage
cohabitation is more widely accepted and
weddings are [ __ ] expensive at this
point marriage could be seen as more of
an achievement of status rather than
something everyone does regardless of
where they are in life of course just
because you're rich and married doesn't
necessarily mean you're monogamous a
study by match.com of all places found
that polyamorous relationships aren't
just for rich influencers like bella
thorne or jake paul there's a
willingness to engage in polyamorous
relationships independent of race gender
and socioeconomic status but the
question continues to puzzle many akora
enthusiasts what relationship formation
are humans actually wired for monogamy
is found only in three to five percent
of animal species but polyamory does
have its challenges for humans from an
evolutionary perspective if fathers
wanted to protect their offspring from
being clubbed by other males they
couldn't just don draper their way
through the paleolithic period instead
they had to stick around and offer
bi-parental care of course this came
with its own reward they could be all
but certain that their kid wasn't the
milkman's though in caveman times that
was the guy who milked mammoths other
fun theories suggest polyamorous
societies could have been wiped out by
stds the jury's still out on whether
we're innately monogamous or polyamorous
but most scientists have concluded we're
somewhere in between in other words
monogamish but evolutionary wiring aside
what's actually best for us as
intelligent and enlightened humans of
the 21st century some contemporary
philosophers would argue that monogamy
is more practical from a resources
standpoint who has the time and
spaghetti budget to lady and the [ __ ]
multiple partners there's also the
problem of jealousy i mean rom-coms and
ideas like true love's kiss are so
deeply entrenched in our psyches from
childhood that we get a little surge of
oxytocin any time we picture our boo
taking some other hottie to the bowling
alley our brains literally don't want us
to share but if that's true then why do
studies show that polyamorous
relationships actually experience less
jealousy than monogamous ones well in
successful poly relationships the
problem of jealousy is addressed through
the idea of compersion which is a
relatively new term for the wholehearted
participation and the joy of others it's
basically the opposite of jealousy where
you'd give your partner a sincere high
five after they slept with channing
tatum without you of course for folks
who aren't into conversion engaging in a
polyamorous relationship may simply be
more stressed than it's worth however
contemporary scholars like harry
chalmers and carrie jenkins lean in the
opposite direction and some go so far as
to say that monogamy isn't even morally
permissible chalmers argues that putting
the brunt of our emotional and sexual
needs on one romantic partner is unfair
and unreasonable especially when
multiple partners could carry the load
why make one person do all that
emotional labor as for jealousy these
philosophers would argue that we don't
restrict friendships so why restrict
lovers romantic love like friendship is
an important human good shouldn't we be
happy for our partner and ourselves to
have more access to channing tatum in
the end it's weird we're all mostly
locked into the monogamy framework by
centuries of reinforcement but of course
it's up for every person to figure out
for themselves monogamy may be a social
construct but so is say using a toilet
as university of washington professor of
psychology david p barash puts it
perhaps what makes human beings special
is our ability to do things that are
unnatural whether those things are
obsolete or like monogamy are socially
imposed in this new to our evolutionary
experience but what do you guys think
should we override our romantic
conditioning to experiment with new
types of relationships is there a future
where polyamory is the norm rather than
the exception let us know what you think
in the comments big thanks to our
patrons for all your support and be sure
to check out our podcast hit that
subscribe button like you're slapping
some sense into the romantic era and
don't forget to ring that bell as always
thanks for watching and
i love you
platonically but but i still love you
see you later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]